- You shared this season
that you're training yourself
to unlove your ex, Tristan.
So, just how'd you do that?
Asking for a friend.
(group laughing)
Just I don't know,
if you have any paper or pen.
(group laughing)
No, it's hard.
I think it's the most
ridiculous thing sometimes.
When something doesn't work out
and you're in a relationship
and you're so deeply in love
and people are like, "oh,
yeah, well why can't you?"
And I'm like, I think I might
always still love that person.
I don't know if that goes away.
- No, and I don't think it
goes away like my ex-husband.
I genuinely still love and
I want the best for him
and I'm rooting for him.
- Absolutely.
- We all, I think, just change or evolve,
that sometimes it's just
not a right fit for you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- When I said I'm learning
how to unlove Tristan,
I think people, whether it be
family or friends or anyone
that you're telling your story to,
they're like, "okay, so move on."
And I'm like, "No."
- Well, let me find the switch.
- Right?
It's not that easy.
Just even the habits that you built,
the repetition, the routine.
When something good happened,
I would call Tristan,
if something bad, that's what I did.
Any little thing, I would
share my life with him,
and so learning to just reprogram myself,
even though if someone
did something bad to me,
it doesn't just mean I'm like,
there's a wall and I've built it up.
I know that this isn't
the right thing for me
and I need to slowly heal and move on
but it doesn't happen over night.